>> Chris: IT'S 11:59 AND 59
SECONDS.
THIS HAPPENED ON VINE TODAY.
"FASHION ROCKS"!
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN LED TO
BELIEVE BY THE FASHION-AND-MUSIC
FUNDRAISER THAT HAPPENED LAST
NIGHT AT BARCLAYS CENTER AS PART
OF NEW YORK FASHION WEEK.
THE AUDIENCE WAS KNOCKED ON ITS
FASHIONABLE ASS WHEN CANADIAN
FEMALE IMPERSONATOR JUSTIN
BIEBER EMERGED FROM HIS SIZZURP
COCOON TO MUMBLE INCOHERENTLY
OFF A TELEPROMPTER WHILE
SUPERMODEL LARA STONE STOOD
THERE WONDERING WHY SHE BOTHERED
TO SHOW UP THE [BLEEP] FOR
REHEARSAL.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
"FASHION ROCKS," PLEASE WELCOME
TO THE STANGE RITA ORA.
>> CHRIS: HE'S GOING TO
( BLEEP ) HIS PANTS TRYING TO
ENGAGE HIS ABS THAT HARD.
AND MAYBE HE DID.
IN CLASSIC BIEBS STYLE, HE
THOUGHT WHAT HE WAS DOING WAS
SUPER TOUGH AND COOL, EVEN
THOUGH IT WAS SUPER NOT.
HE RETWEETED A FAN'S
PEE-SCREAMING VINE, WHICH
CURRENTLY HAS ALMOST 57,000
LIKES AND 58,000 FIRST TWEEN
OVULATIONS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ( SCREAMING )
( LAUGHTER )
I JUST FEEL BAD ABOUT EVERY
FACET OF THAT.
JUSTIN TWEETED "GRANDMA ALWAYS
SAID KILL 'EM WITH KINDNESS AND
THEN STRIP ON LIVE NATIONAL TV.
LOL."
COMEDIANS, WHAT ELSE DID GRANDMA
TELL HIM?
ARDEY MYRIN, GO.
>> YOUR FATHER'S BALL SHOOT
POISON.
CHRIS: ALL RIGHT GREAT, BRODY
STEVENS.
>> WHEN YOU VANDALIZE A
NEIGHBOR'S HOUSE, DON'T GIGGLE.
CHRIS: ALL RIGHT GOOD.
>> RON FUNCHES -- WHERE THE HELL
IS RON FUNCHES?
♪ ♪ (ROCK MUSIC) ♪
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> CHRIS: HEY, RON, WHAT'S UP?
>> AS FIVE-TIME "@MIDNIGHT"
CHAMPION, YOU KNOW I KNOW WHAT
JUSTIN BIEBER'S GRANDMA TOLD
HIM.
SHE SAID SAY YOUR PRAYERS.
EAT YOUR VITAMINS AND PASS THE
REEFER.
IT'S TIME FOR "@MIDNIGHT"!